في مصنع الفولاذ هذا في بلده بوتشا على
بعد 30 كيلومترا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
تتجمع هذه السيدات حاملات معها صور ذويها
مدنيون اوكرانيون سبق وانسجنتهم القوات
الروسيه في هذا المكان قبل ان تحول بعضهم
الى السجون الروسيه والبيلاروسيه
اخذوا ابني وزوجه في نفس اليوم جاءوا الى
منزلنا واخذوهم بعيدا
انقل لي انهم في السجن في روسيا لكنني لا
اعرف اي تفاصيل اخرى
تكافحنا منذ اشهر لايصال صوتهن وللحصول
على معلومات كافيه عن اماكن وجود المساجين
المدنيين تساعدهن في هذه المعركه النائبه
البرلمانيه اولغا فاسيلسكا
قاموا بسجن شخص لان لديه وشم العلم
الاوكراني في ذراعه واخر لديه وشم خارطه
اوكرانيا كامله مع شبه جزيره القرم
المشكله الرئيسيه مع هؤلاء السجناء
المدنيين هي انهم لا يخضعون الاتفاقيات
جنيف لذلك لا يمكن استرجاعهم
في الثالث من شهر مارس اذار الماضي تعرض
فاصله ديميترو الذي كان صحفيا في وكاله
الانباء الاوكرانيه للتعنيف والضرب يقول
الوالد ان خمسه جنود الروس قاموا
بتجريدهما من ملابسهما
فما خان
كنت مسجونا مع ابني هنا القوا بنا على
الارض
في كل مساء كانوا يجلبون سجناء جدد
كان المكان مملوءا وابات ضيقا جدا
[موسيقى]
كانت ايدينا مقيده وعصبوا اعيننا بشريط
لاصق كنا نرى من الاسفل لكن على اي حال لم
يكن هناك ضوء
لا في الليل ولا في النهار
قذف سيل وابنه اسبوعا هنا في ظروف قاسيه
جدا
[موسيقى]
وجدنا برميلا مليئا بالماء في المصنع وقد
كنا نشرب منه
رفضوا ان يقدموا لنا المياه وقالوا لنا
انه لم يعد هناك ماء في القريه اما
بالنسبه للاكل ففي بعض الاحيان كنا نتقاسم
ما تبقى من وجبات الجنود بعد ان يلقوا بها
في الظلام
بعد ايام تم اطلاق سراح الفاصله من الاسر
اما نجله فلا يزال في احدى السجون بجنوب
روسيا حسب اقوال والده
غير بعيد عن بوتشو وفي احدى عيادات بلده
هوستوميل التقينا اولينا رئيسه هذا المركز
الصحي ما زالت هذه الطبيبه تكافح من اجل
استرجاع ابنها
للصليب الاحمر هذه الرساله
ثلاث كلمات فقط
انا على قيد الحياه عندما بدا الغزو
الروسي على اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين
فبراير شباط وجدت اولينا نفسها في قلب
المواجهه
وصل اكثر من 20 ضحيه مدنيه في هوستوميل
قدمنا لهم الاسعافات الاوليه في هذه
العياده لكن الاسوا بالنسبه لهذه الطبيبه
وعائلتها حدث بعد شهر من بدايه الغزو
الروسي في العشرين من مارس اذار كنت احضر
الطعام في فناء البيت على الحطب لانه لم
يكن لدينا كهرباء ولا غاز حينها دخل جندي
روسي واطلق النار على زوجي اصيب في وركه
وركبته اسقطوه ارضا بعدما ضربوه بالبندقيه
ووضعوا مسدسا في فمه واخر في صدره بعدها
سمع ابني الضوضاء فخرج مسرعا جثا على
ركبتيه وتوسل اليهم قائلا لا تقتل ابي ترك
الجنود الروس الجده البالغه من العمر 82
عاما في المنزل واخذوا اولينا وزوجها
المصاب وابنهما على متن عربه عسكريه
بعد استجوابنا اجلسون في الارض
او رؤوسنا
ثم ربطوا هذه الاكياس بشريط لاصق حول
اعناقنا
قال لي ابني امي لم اعد استطيع التنفس
لم اسمع شيئا فظيعا في كل حياتك هذا بعدها
ثقبوا الاكياس حتى نتمكن من التنفس
ونقلونا في سياره مصفحه الى مطار انطونوس
تم اطلاق سراحها بعد ان فقدت وعيها على
امل ان يطلق سراح زوجها وابنها وبعد مرور
شهر ونصف حررت القوات الاوكرانيه بلده
في الايام العشره الاولى بعد تحرير البلده
كان علي فحص جميع الجثث الموجوده في
هوستوميل في كل مره كنت اذهب الى هناك على
امل ان لا اجد ابني وزوجي بينهم رايت
اشخاصا كانت ايديهم مقيده خلف ظهورهم
واصيبوا في مؤخره العنق لقد رايت الكثير
من الاشياء التي لا يمكن تصورها
نيسان عاد زوجه الينا الى المنزل بعد ان
قضى شهرا واحدا في الحبس الاحتياطي في
بيلاروسيا قبل ان ينقل الى روسيا
زوجي عندما رايته لانه خسر 20 كلغ في شهر
واحد بعد عام واحد على الغزو الروسي ما
زالت اولينا والمئات من العائلات
الاوكرانيه تامل في ان يتدخل المجتمع
الدولي من اجل فتح قنوات تواصل مع موسكو
لاطلاق سراح ذويها من السجون الروسيه
والبيلاروسيه